and it's winning now the king can come  to the E3 he's losing and he's losing  the king is stuck in purgatory uh he's  cut off on this diagonal and any check  is going to be checkmates and look at  that yeah he knows his winning report  and actually this one if I remember it  should be quite simple the route goes to  this Square threatening checkmate  and now the Rook moves and this might be  a really clever idea by the bishop not  allowing any checks  think he's gonna win yeah he's going to  win look at Richard loses 100 on the  board oh he's the boss right now yeah  look at him he feels like the boss  Richard reports and look at it he's got  it yeah this is really clever you